elancourt 25000 habitants membres de
l'agglomération de saint quentin en
yvelines devrait être à l'honneur en
2024 lors des jeux olympiques si
seulement les épreuves de vtt ne sont
pas délocaliser à chamonix le dossier
paris 2024 semblait définitif le manque
de clarté des instances olympiques agace
région département et fédération
française de cyclisme mais ravi
certaines associations le prochain maire
devra donc trancher défendre ce projet
au favoriser une délocalisation des
épreuves
autre grand projet à suivre
l'élaboration du commissariat de
circonscription qui regroupera les
effectifs d'elancourt de trappes et de
guyancourt le projet date de 2005 l'état
a donné en 2019 son agrément à là aussi
le choix du prochain maire sera
déterminant l'équipement est annoncée
pour l'instant comme un lieu
d'expérimentation des nouvelles
technologies un commissariat a du futur
et plus largement la ville de demain à
imaginer les questions environnementales
et écologiques s'invite dans le débat a
de la mise en place du bio dans les
menus des cantines à l'accompagnement du
développement de nouveaux modes de
transport côté transports un point
semble avancer le doublement du pont de
lavilledieu vers la verrière reste à
travailler sur les aménagements un
quartier sera aussi à repenser lors de
la prochaine mandature celui des quatre
à avoir une réflexion complète doit être
mené sur cette zone d'activités enfin
durant cette campagne les questions
d'éducation de santé sont aussi abordés
par les candidats dans leur programme
sans oublier un dossier qui occupe
également la campagne dans la ville
voisine de maurepas celui de la
construction d'un nouveau centre
aqualudique et dont la livraison est
annoncée pour 2022